hello
and first off congratulations to you
both i'm so happy the movie is finally
getting a release and on netflix
nonetheless
thank you it's good good stuff thank you
jennifer i'm going to start with you i
often love going back to
first features and discussing the
lasting impressions that they might have
made and obviously yours was on my mind
recently because of the oscars so
even with all the experience that you've
had since dream girls is there anything
about that particular production
that is still influencing the work that
you're doing on sets today
well that was my first time ever acting
so i guess it's my guide for everything
an example and but i'm the type of
person i try to learn
everywhere i go you can never know
enough
and i'm still in film school and steady
learning
so i do try to pull from that as much as
i can it never ends and it's not
supposed to
that's right first film at the gate you
get the oscar you're supposed to like
you know retire
you know what i might have to after this
next one
jeffrey i can throw a similar question
your way
with uh basquiat not necessarily your
first
feature but i think it was the first
on-screen lead at least
so was there anything about that
particular film especially working with
julian schnabel and that incredible cast
around you that you still find
influencing how you approach your work
today that experience
was kind of a baptism you know with a
group of incredible artists the artists
that had
influenced me inspired me david bowie
uh dennis hopper chris walken
gary oldman who was like
as a young actor was a guy i looked to
and
and went wow this we can go here now
i mean he was definitely a guy who
opened my eyes to certain possibilities
you know with this stuff
and so to work with those guys to be
gathered you know
and really kind of leading the charge
with them you know uh
uh yeah that was that that that would
that that will never no that'll never
not be with me
and it was a it was a beautiful
wonderful way
to kind of uh you know open the doors on
this thing for me
so now with all that in mind for both of
you i know monster wasn't
kelvin's first film but back then it was
one of his
very first i guess substantial
headlining roles and
feels like a really challenging one from
my limited perspective at least
so given your experiences what was it
important for both of you to do
on set for him as a scene partner in
order to
best support his first big lead
performance or one of them
calvin's what he's like 85 years old now
right
i mean we made this movie
you know what five years ago now
uh when he was a yeah he was uh he was a
youngster he was
you know a young man a younger man now
but he's
you know he's he's come a long
way from then because it has been so
long since the
you know the film was made but i don't
think there was anything
at least from my perspective that i
tried to do
beyond uh play his father
and you know the the film is so
wonderfully cast
there was a i think kind of an immediate
sense of family between all of us you
know it was just clear who we were
why we were and what we were supposed to
give to one another
it was really it was really in the best
way
easy because we you know we were all
just throwing that you know that that
that vibe into the mix
and and of course it rotated around
kelvin you know so
uh he gave uh uh jennifer gave i tried
to you know to give my part
and just roll with it it's weird
thinking about
everything that he's accomplished since
making this movie but still thinking of
this movie as one of his big firsts
because he's had so many incredible
titles since
jennifer i'll come to you on this one
and a true first with this because it
was anthony's first feature as a
director
so even with the countless music videos
that he's directed
over the years what was it about your
very first meeting with him
that made you say that you know like
anthony is the guy to direct
this film wow actually it's
it started out when we did a music video
of mine
and i was like you're gonna direct the
film one day
he's like and you're gonna be in it i
said i will be there so that's kind of
how
um we ended up syncing up together um
and me being a part of this project
because anthony miller is an amazing
director
and now you get to see his amazing work
through film which i'm just
proud to be a part of it when you were
on that music video set what was it
about
his work there that made you say like
that's a cinematic quality of his work
the quality it wasn't that just of you
know music videos is his own language
like i've done
film i've done commercial you know
videos
and each thing has his own style and
language
and way in quality and i could sense in
his quality
of work through his photography and
through his videos
like no that's a heavier hand right
there in a
eye with more depth i could sense that
in his work and
so i'm not surprised to see him you know
come this far and to do filming i think
there will be far more
and and i'm very proud of this project
because i know it's in the right hands
i'm very much looking forward to seeing
more so i know this
part of the process is out of your hands
as actors in the film but i was
wondering what it was like from your
perspectives
after the film hit sundance in 2018 and
then you're waiting waiting waiting for
it to get
this release is there any period of
nerves and now in the end
are you sitting there going hey it was
worth the wait we're on netflix
well i mean i i was a little frustrated
that
the film hadn't found
a home immediately after sundance when
we when we screened there
this film got a reaction uh that
is rare there was a standing ovation for
this film
that rolled on and
it's a function of the power of the
story uh
obviously the direction of the film and
i think it's particularly a function
of the work that kelvin put in
and what was really more disappointing
to me than anything you know jennifer
talks about her first uh her first film
and the success sheet
and you know grabbing the the oscar i've
seen a lot of young actors
who get a first role they come out
and they get a nomination and uh
you know are celebrated and received
you know by their peers and i was
incredibly disappointed
for kelvin that he didn't have that
opportunity with this film
because there's not been a performance
that i've seen
by a young actor that surpasses this
performance
of all of the young actors that have
come through and there's some there's
some really talented guys
i haven't seen one uh who's who's been
recognized uh with an oscar nod
that surpasses what kelvin does in this
film so i'm really pleased for him
uh that the work will will finally be
out there we'll see where it goes those
are other things that are out of our
control
but at the very least audiences will
will now have an opportunity to take in
the work that he's given in this film
so happy for him thank you guys so much
for your time today and again huge
congratulations on monster
thank you thank you